So the first algorithm that we're going to cover today is called reduce.
So an example of reducing a set of numbers, for example,
is adding up all the numbers in this set to get a total sum.
Reduce is an interesting algorithm because it requires cooperating between processors.
So here we have a tree that we can use to compute the sum of a large number of integers.
And so it's interesting because we now have dependencies between the operations.
First, we add 1 and 2, and we have to take the result and then add it to 3.
Then when we have that sum, we can take the result and add it to 4 and so on.
So we now have dependencies between the operations that we need to do.
And we haven't looked at any algorithms that have this behavior before.
Reduce is also interesting because a parallel implementation,
like the one that we're about to describe,
will have a smaller and a better number of steps than a serial implementation.